what's going on everybody welcome back
to the cosmic wonder where we talk all
things marvel and mcu i'm your host
warren thompson and today we have some
very exciting news concerning the future
of the marvel cinematic universe and
this is actually coming from kevin feige
the president of marvel studios himself
over the past couple of weeks we have
been speculating here on the channel
that marvel studios is about to reveal a
lot about their next phase and it looks
like we were right on the money there as
kevin feige has told us in a recent
interview that phase four is almost at
an end and the next phase is about to
begin and kevin feige even says that
we're going to get a little bit more of
a glimpse into this new saga and going
to be able to see a tiny bit of where
it's actually heading so from iron man 1
leading all the way up to spider-man
fire from home that was the infinity
saga obviously because it focused around
the infinity stones but what is this
next saga focusing around right now
there hasn't really been too many common
themes between all of the different
disney plush shows in the movies but i
do believe we do know where this saga is
going i believe we know what's going to
be revealed as the big picture of this
next saga and when it's going to happen
and we're going to break it all down in
this video so if you're new be sure to
subscribe so you don't miss out on any
of the latest mcu news so first off
let's start off with the quote from
kevin feige talking about how phase four
is about done and getting a glimpse and
a reveal into the next phase and this
entire saga in general this was in an
interview with games radar and kevin
feige says that phase 5 is almost here
in the interview when talking about the
future he said as we're nearing the end
of phase 4 i think people will start to
see where this next saga is going i
think there have been many clues already
that are at least apparent to me of
where this whole saga is going but we'll
be a little more direct about that in
the coming months to set a plan so
audiences who want to see the bigger
picture can see a tiny tiny tiny bit
more of the road map this is incredible
news especially for those people who say
that marvel studios isn't really
connecting right now there's not much
connectivity and we can't really see
where it's going well it's almost like
kevin feige has been on the internet and
has heard all of these complaints and
now he's saying don't worry all is about
to be revealed and you'll get a pretty
good idea of where everything is going
pretty soon now as i mentioned i believe
we know where everything is kind of
heading to but at the same time it would
be really cool if marvel threw us a
curveball and kind of included some
projects that we really weren't
expecting that just come way out of left
field because we know a lot of exciting
projects are coming up like the
thunderbolts the fantastic four the
young avengers are being set up in the
mcu right now but it would be really
cool if he announced something that we
just really weren't expecting which
might happen but let's break down what
he said the first thing that he said is
phase 4 is almost at an end now this is
kind of funny to me not because of what
he said but because of what people have
been thinking in my videos when i talk
about a lot of the upcoming projects i
mentioned that a lot of these well-known
projects that have already been
announced are going to be phase 5 but
people have been saying they are phase
4. that is not the case keep in mind
kevin feige revealed the entire phase 4
slate at 2019 and it ends with thor love
and thunder yes marvel studios announced
a lot more after that but they never
said that it was a part of phase 4 but
they also didn't say it was a part of
phase five so i understand but if you
keep that in mind then we actually know
a lot about phase five blade captain
marvel 2 ant-man and the wasp
quantomania black panther wakanda
forever guardians of the galaxy vol 3
and the fantastic four these are most
likely our phase 5 movies hopefully some
of them do bleed a little bit into phase
4 even though marvel's phase 4 lineup
did end with thor love and thunder
hopefully they include a little bit more
into phase 4. that way we have more
surprises coming for phase 5 but even if
we do know a decent amount about phase 5
here's why it's still really really
exciting that marvel studios is actually
going to make an announcement soon now
one is that there are always secret
projects with marvel keep in mind during
phase 4 we knew a decent amount about
what was to come but they still hit us
with some projects that we didn't expect
which was really nice but two according
to kevin feige there's going to be a lot
of clarity offered to us as far as the
direction of where everything is going
that's where marvel studios is going to
give us some new information now kevin
feige says that there have been many
clues already that have been very
apparent to him of where the saga is
going and i think a lot of us especially
if you follow my channel have all been
thinking kind of the same thing of where
the mcu was going and i have
specifically talked about many times how
the mcu is now splitting into different
categories we have the cosmic side which
is movies like guardians of the galaxy
thor love and thunder captain marvel 2.
you might even consider miss marvel a
part of that because she seems to have
cosmic powers you have the dark side the
magical side which is one division the
scarlet witch doctor strange in the
multiverse of madness the agatha
harkness series coming up which we'll
probably get more information about that
pretty soon and then you have the
grounded side of the mcu which is sort
of the falcon and the winter soldier the
thunderbolts when they finally come the
hawkeye show and black widow movies like
those and then we have this new godly
side of the mcu with the eternals with
moon knight and thor love and thunder is
apparently going to be a pretty big
godly movie and what i mean by that and
most people know by now is that thor
love and thunder has been revealed to be
sort of a detective movie thor and jane
foster's the mighty thor along with the
rest of their crew are going to be going
across the universe trying to discover
who is killing all of these different
types of gods so they're going to
introduce more than one different type
of god thor and odin are norse gods but
we know we're going to be seeing zeus in
this movie who is a greek god in moon
knight we got egyptian gods so who knows
what else we'll see in this movie now
ultimately i think if you combine all of
these different segments of the mcu and
think about loki doctor strange and the
multiverse of madness and ant-man and
the wasp quantomania it seems like we
are in the multiversal saga especially
with the post credit of multiverse of
madness telling us that doctor strange
is going to yet again dive more into the
multiverse and incursions and i think
these are the hints that kevin feige is
talking about because like i've been
saying for probably over a couple of
years now this is all going to lead to
secret wars in the comics incursion is
actually how secret war starts and now
we've literally heard about incursion
from mr fantastic himself who in the
comics actually plays a major major role
now of course that wasn't our main mcu
earth 616 mr fantastic but i'm hoping
that they actually reveal pretty soon
that he is indeed going to be playing
the main one john krasinski and i think
these things are what's going to be
announced and i think they're going to
be announced at disney's d23 expo kevin
feige said we'll be a little more direct
about that in the coming months well
disney plus day and disney's d23 expo
are both in september that's only a few
months away but also san diego comic-con
is coming up as well even though rumor
has it that marvel studios won't
actually have a panel or a hall but
they'll have a slight presence there
however the reason for that is because
they plan to reveal a lot at d23 and
disney plus day so for those who are
wondering about the future of the mcu
where it's going how it's all going to
be connected you only have to wait a few
months and don't forget that kevin feige
could have also been talking about a
specific movie or post-credits scene
that could be shown in say thor lover
thunder or miss marvel because don't
forget they revealed thanos in a
post-credits scene so they could reveal
galactus or john krasinski as our main
mr fantastic or anything really big they
could reveal in a post-credits scene so
hopefully we get a little bit of
information through other movies and
projects before september but look out
for september because it looks like some
really really big announcements about
the future of the mcu are coming from
marvel studios president kevin feige
himself and of course i'll be covering
the entire thing and telling you
everything you need to know so if you
don't want to miss out on any of that
news be sure to subscribe to the channel
and hit that notification bell don't
forget to give the video a like and for
live updates you can follow me on
instagram and twitter as always thank
you all so much for watching woof